yeah yeah yeah
all right
let's
do it
all right y'all welcome to riffing with
griffin shout out to detective design
and dopa pod who made these dope themes
for me thought i'd pull this oldie but
goodie out this is another one that they
made so
as you know welcome to your
favorite podcast
[Music]
ripping red
[Music]
all right today everybody we gonna be
talking about the big news of course
elon buys twitter and what does it mean
nba playoffs you know i love that i want
to get into katie and kyrie getting
swept
i've been talking about this forever and
of course i finally started watching
the winning time
show on hbo so we're going to talk about
that too but welcome
wow
[Music]
you like funk music
you gotta check out dopapod they're just
a dope funk band
play that [ __ ] music white boy
all right anyways
welcome back to riffing with griffin
y'all we are live and in full effect i
got a poll up
how important is twitter for gathering
information
you know is it very
important to you do you get a lot of
information from twitter is that your
go-to source for news and information or
or like you know you want to find out
what a candidate thinks in a in a thing
or you want to like find out if a show
is great or not do you go to twitter do
you you know how do you get your
information is twitter your source is it
very important is it somewhat important
you know or it's like man sort of
important or is it like am you know you
skim through it but it's like whatever
you don't really care
or you never use it because it just
sucks to you
um i saw an article about uh that like
actually there's that women don't like
using twitter just because of the
the trolling and the
whatever so i don't know if there's any
ladies in here right now do you use
twitter like how important is twitter to
you let me know you know what i mean
like say hey in
in in the comments in the chats we are
live ladies and gentlemen we are live so
thank you as always for watching we're
from griffin please subscribe and share
i you know i got some big changes coming
to riffing with griffin i just
i just i don't know man i don't know
i i got to do more uh you know so i
still got my patreon so make sure you
guys check that out too if you if you're
interested in um
you know getting more content
how i'm gonna be doing that is i'm gonna
go live on twitch just chat
subscriber chat only
do my episode there and then
you if you're a subscriber already on
twitch then you get to watch it there
or you get to watch it on patreon or you
get to watch it as a youtube member
those three sources i have for extra
content so more of that is coming i
promise i know i've been like behind but
you know i'm doing this by myself i'm
actually gonna get i'm actually gonna
get a real real real producer like a
producer producer
uh i know it's like a long time coming
right guys i know you guys get on me
about that but i'm gonna do it um you
know i love wiggy wiggy wasn't
necessarily gonna be a producer he was
just there to help me out and that's
he's that he's become like a dear friend
of mine so shout out to wiggy and i will
have him come back around and do some
stuff but you know it was always a trial
just to see what it was and i just
realized we ain't not too much alike in
terms of like
you know so artisty and like you know
we're both kind of flaky
that's
so i need like i need a task master
producer who's like eric i need this
this and this and we got to do it now i
need that him and i are too much alike
we end up going to dinner
hanging out or even when we're doing the
podcast we end up just like we're just
yapping and talking and stuff so it's
like i need more of like somebody who's
like boom boom boom boom boom for the
stuff so and even if you're out there
and you're interested because you know i
need like
you know even all these people to hit me
up like i want to be your intern i want
to do this
it's like i i i
it'll be like a
paid intern as i grow but it's got to be
consistent i can't have somebody dip in
and dip out i need somebody consistent
so i'm working on that as i'm talking to
a bunch of my good buddies that are like
deep into this you know
so you know this was at first like a
hobby and something fun to do and then
the pandemic and it was like hey you
know you do a podcast because all the
comics are doing podcasts but i actually
really love this i love the community i
love coming on live and doing it like
this but you know i could do more um you
know i could do more and i'm challenging
myself to do more so look out for that
so make sure you uh you know subscribe
share like and also as always i'm on
twitch too i twitch every day
as i was saying if you go to eric
griffin gaming i twitch if you like
watching you know gameplay and i do that
a lot you know and quick uh i got
something to if you're if you're in the
cleveland area check this out funny and
i'm also bringing guess who oh mr rick
glassman is coming with me from take i
don't know why that went like that see
this is what i'm talking about about
needing a producer
it wasn't supposed to be like it's
supposed to start from the beginning get
shoes off it's gonna be me and rick
bringing the funny so who knows what's
gonna happen but make sure you get there
april 28 to the 30th and check out the
tickets on ericgriffin.com
okay well that was supposed to be a good
commercial so here it is again
just bear with me everybody that's
watching
what's up everybody this is eric griffin
and guess what i'm coming to cleveland
so cleveland get yourself ready i'm
gonna be at hilarity's april 28th to the
30th bringing the funny and i'm also
bringing guess who
mr rick glassman is coming with me from
take his shoes off it's going to be me
and rick bringing the funny so who knows
what's going to happen but make sure you
get there april 28 to the 30th and check
out the tickets on eric griffin.com
okay
like that could have been smoother right
you know what i mean
i'll shut up in the chat you know you're
such haters man
you know what you're getting the timeout
and if you're listening live on like if
you're listening not even live apple and
all that stuff thank you for listening
to the podcast but i'm doing it live and
sometimes people are just a-holes so i
gotta you know give them time-outs
i need more moderators in my chat but
anyways uh welcome to roofing with
griffin let's get to it as i say i'll be
in uh
you know cleveland uh this coming
weekend so anyways
uh uh what happened this week nothing
major happened this week for me i like
to talk about me a little bit uh you
know the wedding's coming up guys my
wedding's coming up in in uh like in
june
so how do i feel
i'm excited you know
i'm a little nervous and anxious but the
people that are married i guess you you
have these kinds of feelings right but
i'm actually pretty excited i've turned
into a groom zilla um
more people are coming to the wedding
than we had actually planned so that's
gonna cost me a grip but it's like you
know i plan that that's the only time
i'm ever gonna do this and so it's uh
you know it's it's it's exciting so i'm
like excited i'm nervous i'm like i
don't know i have so many different
emotions and feelings but uh um but i'm
ready for it you know and then it's like
now i'm just thinking about now i'm
nervous about it what am i gonna say and
uh what are people gonna say what you
know i don't know it's like there's so
many things to think about it when
you're doing something like this there's
a lot of pressure and all this kind of
stuff so you know i think rachel and i
are both feeling a little anxiety but
it's still very much gung-ho and excited
about it so
that's coming on
so we got that so but anyways let's just
get to it oh you know what i wasn't even
supposed to have this background up this
whole time you know i like to like put
it in later damn it see that's what i'm
saying i'm all messed up today but
whatever it doesn't matter
so let's talk about it the big news is
elon musk finally bought twitter
how do you feel about it i got this poll
up right now you know is it if you just
want to write a comment later how how
important is twitter to you you get all
your information from it i don't know
but anyway so there's like all this talk
you know there's all this uh big talk
about like what does this mean and elon
musk has put out a lot of information
saying about a lot of um
quotes a lot of like statements you know
about he wants to be an advocate for
free speech he wants this to be the
place where like you know you could go
on and say anything and do anything for
you know free speech purposes and uh you
know
and like you know how do i feel about
that i mean i i kind of felt like that
thing was like that already and then you
have these like you know
uh fox news sort of people who were like
you know elon musk is going to be able
to control the information he's going to
turn down the algorithm for you know
certain candidates and all this kind of
stuff and i thought to myself
weren't they sort of doing that anyway
or they could have been doing that
anyway so the first thing i want to talk
about is like you know people are making
this big deal about this guy owning it
right but who owns it already
who owned twitter who was in charge who
was making choices who was the person
that made the choice that trump for
instance had to be taken off twitter who
makes the choices for like their
policies about hate speech and
who they're taking it off like how come
nobody was concerned about who was who
owned twitter before that so like i
actually went to the i had to like you
know i said let me go to the the
internet and look i said who owned 200
before this is from yahoo so you know it
was like um you know so he bought it for
55 a share
um
i don't know wait i thought this article
told me who owned twitter before him
uh
let's see
um
i don't know on
apparently it was like
it was owned by individual investors
um
twitter co-founder jack dorsey among the
top shareholders
um
[Music]
like
banks
you know it's like
uh an addition of vanguard institutional
investors included morgan stanley
investment management blackrock fund
investors
anyway my point is
who are these people
you know who are these people that own
twitter and why were we never concerned
about
what their agenda was
up until this point and maybe you were
maybe you're one of these people that
was like i was always concerned about uh
what twitter what was going on with
twitter but like
i'm sitting here now and people are so
concerned about
elon musk owning twitter and i'm like
well
at least now we have accountability at
least now the buck stops with one guy so
like if you don't like whatever's
happening with twitter we know who owns
it now we know like hey he made the
choice he's in charge and then you can
decide you know what i don't want to be
on twitter see right now i think it's
better that we know everything
transparency because up to this point
right now who makes these policies at
twitter like who's in charge of the
day-to-day we have no idea at least now
there's a face
so like if you feel like hey this is too
left-leaning it's too right-leaning it's
too
uh there's too much hate speech there's
too much whatever at least now we could
be like yo we can actually tweet at the
guy hey man what the hell is going on
with uh twitter i don't like this
even if there's organizations that feel
like hey uh you know we don't like
what's going on we don't like that
twitter represents this they at least
know where the buck stops
i think that's great
i mean we didn't know social media was
going to be like this sort of like
juggernaut of influence
it's a hugely influential thing
so
now we have this guy who's influenced
the world
in a way that is like unquantifiable
almost you know
like he's single-handedly
we're not single-handedly but
he's
largely responsible for
what's happening with electric cars you
know like just what he did for his
company
um
the spacex program
just so many different things that this
guy's just a brilliant guy
and he's so accessible i love that he
tweets i love that he like is out there
he's not this sort of like billionaire
recluse that you don't know anything
about even though we don't really know
anything about them other than these
little things that come out it still
feels kind of like hey this guy seems
like like one of us almost right just
with 300 billion dollars
you know so
i i just i don't know
i don't know what if i personally have a
big problem with this one guy owning it
um again i just bring up again i didn't
i never know who owned it before that i
never know where the buck stopped i
never knew where who was responsible for
making certain choices you know when i'm
on twitter and somebody's trolling and
hating on me and saying like really like
you guys don't know
people say really terrible things to
people on twitter man like terrible
things you know you get like they attack
you personally they talk about your your
family they you know there's people out
there who are just like they're in the
chat sometimes too there's people that
just have
their life is so
their life is so worthless you know uh
their their parents didn't give them
attention and the only kind of attention
they want to put out is negativity it's
because a piece of them is lost so i
always feel sorry for so i never get
necessarily mad what i get mad about is
when somebody says something about like
what i believe in if they misinterpret
what i'm saying
i get mad about that
because i feel like hey you're you're
being whatever but when people say like
truly mean things that kind of [ __ ]
never bugs me
call me fat come say whatever it never
bugs you because you don't know me so
it's like
how can that hurt anyone if someone
doesn't know you even whatever they say
what does it matter you know what i mean
so anyways my point is that kind of
stuff happens on twitter on a daily
basis to people
celebrities you know
it's crazy right
so i never know who was in charge of
that before who can i go to i've
reported people many times and i get
these emails back from twitter like hey
sorry like i'm actually going to read an
email that i got from twitter because
somebody said some like some super
horrible stuff to me and i was like oh
man like we can't this this can't they
really gonna let this go
right and then i got this thing from
twitter support and it said we are
writing to let you know after reviewing
the available information we didn't find
a violation of our rules in the content
you reported
wow and so i was like damn so even if i
go to like the rules what are the
twitter rules
so the twitter rules are violence you
may not threaten violence against an
individual or group of people okay that
seems pretty self-explanatory you may
not threaten or promote terrorism all
right child exploitation exploitation
obviously abuse or harassment though you
may not engage in targeted harassment of
someone
what
you may not engage in targeted
harassment of someone
if i read you this tweet that this
person sent me i'm not going to because
i'm not going to give to do any kind of
love
i'm like damn
so if they're saying they reviewed it
and they went ah what he said was cool
that makes me feel like like who who's
in charge over there so that's my point
anyway so
i i just again i just don't know
what
i don't know what this
means i don't know what any of it means
so now we at least know
here's the guy he's in charge
so
you know it's
twitter ain't government run
this is not like the government's
running twitter it's not the post office
where we could go in there and be like
yo you can't do this and that uh you
know and then you know how then it
becomes like very woke and then like a
very small minority of people get to
make huge changes to like everything you
know a very very small very small
segment of society has changed public
bathrooms
not that any of us cared anyway
honestly like normal people
i never cared about the bathroom i'm
just let me just speak for me i'm
someone that never cared about who came
in and out of the bathroom i never
worried about it
to me it was only like very weird
like weird sensitive christian men were
the only ones that were worried about
this and then they carried that off to
their christian women and their family
and made them like you know oh this is
like those kind of weird christian [ __ ]
that's the only people that cared how
many times have you been in a bathroom
gal how many times have you been in the
bathroom dudes this is just for the
dudes you in a bathroom you had a club
or a bar you're at some place that's
super crowded and you're in the bathroom
you're peeing and a woman storms in the
bathroom right and she goes oh my god
i'm so sorry but i have to be you know
and she just goes to the stall
we don't care
how many dudes like hey you get out of
here this is something this is a male
gender bathroom only we just we look
nobody cares and we just look back we
finish our pee and we get out of there
nobody cares so they made this sort of a
big deal and made a fight for this very
small segment of society that was like
you know now now
all the places are like gender neutral
bathroom all gender bathroom or they
they just have one bathroom and they
lock it or they have like you know
that's what they do now and it's like oh
it wasn't a big deal because there's
nothing to fight about anymore so now
nobody cares so you know that's what i'm
saying about like what's going on on
twitter it's like
there's all this fighting and discourse
and stuff going on
and if he's saying well that's for uh
you know uh free speech and i go okay
great people have discourse people can
disagree
and apparently people can say terrible
things about you and your family right
people can harass you on twitter
and no one cares okay
so at in and in this same place you can
get information from the president
you know what's your favorite movie uh
when's your favorite comedian gonna be
in a certain town so here's a place
where all of this information and you
have to decipher on your own what's
important or not important uh what you
know and so it's a public it's not a
it's not a it's a private company now uh
but it was never government run where we
could go in and like make changes it was
always something that's your choice you
don't like twitter delete it
you don't ever have to look at it
you know what i mean you just you don't
ever have to look at it
so who cares right
so
one of the things i heard him say that i
really i hope he does is
he wants to verify that each person has
to verify that they're a real person for
their account
to me i think everybody should have to
have their name on their account your
username don't gotta be your name but
when i click your name and your profile
it should say first last name
this is who that person is
because there's too many cowards on here
running their mouth
and then they're just
keyboard warriors you never know who
they are you know exactly who i am you
can even find me because you can look at
my schedule and be like i'm gonna go
talk to this guy because he's gonna be
at cleveland the 28th through the 30th
in hilarities and you could be like hey
i'm that guy that tweeted this
i can't find you
i can't find you you you you out here
just behind a stupid username
boobybooby77 you know that's you i i'm
out here i'm eric griffin
boom so i hope that
i wish he would they would do that but
you know it is what it is there's a lot
of bots and uh scams and and all this
stuff and he's talking about weeding
that out so you know who knows what's
gonna happen with that so the guy bought
twitter you know what i mean
all right so here's
something the question that i had i
tweeted this
and i just and maybe this is something
we can discuss you know if if you're in
um
you know you're
on the on the thing
um if you guys are hearing that like
little noise something's supposed to
come on the screen actually
something's supposed to come on the
screen to show like like who's making uh
like super chats or follows supposed to
come on the screen but it's not coming
on the screen so let me just get rid of
that because it's like only doing this
making noises and not showing anything
so anyway and thanks again for listening
and watching and being here live and and
re-watching and all that kind of stuff
so
here's something i tweeted i don't know
and and this is a honest question
why don't he just make his own app
i mean
44 billion dollars
you can't make your own app for like how
much does it cost
so
some people have already pushed back and
said to me like well he's buying the
user base he's buying that it's already
something that's established
but
still to me i just feel like he's so
popular and famous he's got millions of
followers on twitter and other social
media platforms how much does it cost to
make an app
so even if he put 500 million in a
really great app
and then he spent
a million dollars on super bowl ads two
million dollars on super bowl ads five
million dollars an ad he got like all
the he paid for all the famous people in
the world to like you know five or six
people to do a and then he was like join
you know eat elon book musk book join
must book and then he like bought ads
all over the country how much would that
cost
how much would it cost to buy all the
major billboards in all the major cities
how much would it cost to buy local ad
space
on television programs and do like a
blitz for like
a year to get people to join must book
you don't think i mean tick tock did it
like didn't wasn't tic toc nothing and
isn't that some foreign company that we
don't even know who owns that and
everybody's on that and everybody's
using that why couldn't he do that why
did he have to spend 44 billion dollars
i just feel like
seems like a waste of money to me
like what else could he have done with
his money
you know i think he could like i'm just
saying if he feels like free speech is
the most important thing i might feel
like there's so many other things that
you know he could do in our country with
44 billion dollars and i don't want to
seem like some bleeding heart liberal
type guy but no matter what whatever it
your cause is is what i'm saying was
this a great use of money spent spending
money is all i'm saying seems like a
overpayment to me i don't know justify
it for me in the in the in the comments
in chat like
i just
i don't get it
i honestly don't get it i mean
i feel like let's say you're someone
that's if you're like a billionaire like
that and you're into the arts i mean
think of all the things you could do
with 44 billion dollars uh you know i
mean you could
like like he could have like a contest
amongst high schools and the top
thousand high schools get
like a million dollar endowment that
goes into an investment account and then
for three years they get to spend the
interest
on that money for their arts program
that's just one idea i'm saying so it's
not even like he's giving his money away
you know he's putting he's putting a
million dollars into some sort of like
mutual bond investment account or
whatever how that works and and for
three years you know you they're earning
the interest and these kind of accounts
some kind sometimes get six six to
twenty percent you know what what could
that money do for a local school's arts
program if you're into that you know
okay you're in the free speech uh maybe
you you know like oprah i think oprah
started at her own network for like 300
million uh
that's you know and now it's finally i
mean he got enough money okay well start
your own news you know i don't know i
mean i'm saying there's so many
different things if you if you care
about the homeless
uh what could you do with uh that money
to help the homeless if that's your
thing um if you care about you know um i
just i don't know i just i just feel
like
he said free speech is the most is it's
super important to him and it's not
about the money but i don't believe it's
not about the money i think he's gonna
find a way to make his money back you
know what i mean
you know what i'm saying i've
i feel like this guy
he's gonna he's gonna find a way he's
gonna find a way to make his money back
right
you know i think we i think we all agree
with that
um wow i'm still getting these these
noises i don't know if you guys can hear
that but whatever
i'll figure it out later
so
you know
you know just whatever your agenda is if
you think like what could he have done
with this because i know there's like
you know of course there's a lot of
bleeding hearts out there there's
somebody that thinks like
like because here's another thought and
i'm just giving you thoughts you know
so if you're a billionaire like that you
have hundreds of billions of dollars you
know and you're saying you don't care
about money
uh
if you're saying like you care about
helping then it's like then why is your
car a hundred thousand dollars
to buy
so i'm saying like if you don't care
about money and you care about the
importance of say putting electric cars
in people's hands because you see the
value for the environment or whatever
the point of it is why is your car a
hundred thousand dollars
like then why isn't there like a you
know why isn't your car thirty thousand
dollars
uh and then you're not making 300
billion but you're maybe you're making
75 billion
and then more people get your product so
it's like when i hear somebody talk
about they don't care about money
if you've accumulated 300 billion
dollars
you care about money you know what i
mean like you
so it's like it's not even about him
spending his money on people but he
could just make less by offering his
product for less
uh he could give away the electricity
you know all the superchargers and he
could put them all over the place and be
like yeah i'm i'm fronting the bill with
the money i make you could you could
charge for free all over the country and
not just people would not you don't even
have to just own a tesla you could you
could uh uh
you know you could i have a jaguar i
have a you know electric jaguar hey you
you can come charge here too like why
not do that i mean this is just thoughts
man i'm just saying don't tell me you
don't care about money because you care
about money um
you know what i'm saying
oh and i'm not trying to hide anything
uh i see i see there's someone in here
eric is a liberal but tries to hide it i
ain't trying to hide [ __ ] i'm writing
them i'm in the middle i'm in the middle
on the liberal side but i'm at the
border that's where i'm at
i'm totally at the border i'm more
liberal in a lot of ways but i'm at the
border and i'm not trying to hide [ __ ]
my opinion is right here uh you don't
have to like you know like you think
that's an insult like this idiot thinks
it's an insult to say to me eric is a
liberal i yeah
uh
i like there's a lot of liberal policies
i like
uh uh you know
especially social things
but i'm way more conservative when it
comes to like financial things and like
the choices that we should make i think
the hard choices should come from the
more conservative side yeah i just
there's nothing wrong with that you know
uh so
if if if you think that's an insult
hey two middle fingers to you go go
someplace else where you can go hear
somebody like go go watch fox news
why are you here
anyways
see that's the kind of stuff that that
is something that makes me mad talk
about how fat i am and all that kind of
stuff i don't care
saying dumb [ __ ] like that that's what
makes me upset
anyways
um i don't know what your cause is
whatever it is but like i say uh i think
that even if free speech is your
your your you know the thing you're
you're white whale
isn't there other things you could do
with your 44 billion dollars to in
really ensure more free speech
uh i would love him to start a network
that is like you know and he grabs
people from fox that he likes he grabs
people from cnn he overpays them to come
and they're sitting there talking
together and having a a good discourse
about news as opposed to like when you
watch either one of these news programs
you totally feel the agenda i would love
an agenda-free news outlet
so i mean i'm just saying like there's
so many ways to like push out free
speech other than spending 44 billion
dollars on twitter so that's my
you know that's my question
i'm gonna end this poll
and start a new poll
was
was this the wait [ __ ] i can't type was
this the best was this the best
use of 44 billion
or whatever it was how about this of
his
billions
you know
what do you guys think you know what i
mean
you know what i mean um
yeah yeah so i i just i just don't know
i mean a lot of people fight were
fighting with me on this twitter and i
don't know why you fight i i it's an
honest question this is just like i'm
just giving i'm just asking an honest
question like
is this the best use of 44 54 billion
well however many billions it is
if your agenda is free speech is twitter
the place that we want to fight for free
speech is that the best place
so i don't know even even like i say
even if you have a super liberal agenda
if you have a super liberal agenda
uh that you think hey this is what we
could do with the money or even if you
have some right wing agenda and what
would that even be you know i think the
right i think the the two agendas
actually come to the same place but they
just come at it at a different way
you know so it's like
to me it's like if you invest in schools
and in education
uh then people are
going to be they're not going to be
there's less people who are poor and
then now we have more money that to use
on the roads and and
whatever whatever else the
infrastructure of the country and that
kind of stuff you know you know you know
what i mean like if we educate people
then they have they have their own
worth to to to go into the workforce and
do all that kind of stuff so i mean
you could come at it from two different
ways i mean they just it just ends up in
the same place
i don't know man you think i got the
answer i'm just a freaking comedian i'm
just talking we're just having a
discourse we're talking right now well
i'm talking and you're listening but you
know you guys are in the chat you're in
the comments
and we're just trying to figure out what
the hell is going on right so
i don't know we'll probably keep talking
about this and we'll see what happens
with it but it is very fascinating
uh
in closing about this issue it's
fascinating to me how people are so
upset about
the the people that are upset like the
liberal people who are like oh he why
weren't they upset about who owned the
[ __ ] in the first place you know you
know what i mean like it don't make any
sense to me at least now the buck stops
with him and we can now see some
transparency and some accountability
for this guy
because you know and i think that he's
up for the challenge
you know so i think i think it's in
closing i feel like it's a good thing i
don't i don't think it's good or bad
actually i just think it's like whatever
a rich guy bought something for a lot of
money and he has a plan to do and then
we'll see if it works out
you know what i mean if not then we just
stop using twitter and then whoever
comes out with the next thing will use
that maybe he'll get in and just what if
he got it just to get rid of it that
would be great like he just cut like he
buys it and he goes i never liked
twitter
he he he has like
he shows a button and he goes delete and
then twitter just disappears
that would be dope i would be like golf
clap to you man
um
[Music]
anyways
all right so
that's that
that is that all right so let's go to
where are we now let's go to our
um
let's go to our nba playoff talk
nba playoffs y'all
nba playoffs
so it's nba time
all right so i'm just going to talk
about this one series
right now and that was
you know
the the nets and the celtics now if you
watch my podcast regularly
you know i've been talking about this
i have been talking about this for a
while
i even had a whole thing where i showed
you some numbers
how kevin durant
when it truly matters
he's had some tough games
against lebron james oklahoma city
versus miami
there was two games where he had really
bad games
it cost them the series
against golden state when they were up
3-1
they lost that series and there were two
games one in particular where he didn't
show up
now this year
the first two games of a very important
series
my man don't show up
charles barkley had a whole thing about
being a bus driver and being a passenger
i don't know if it's so harsh like that
but i do think
kevin durant don't got that thing
it's just he's a great talent
i mean phenomenal talent but in terms of
team success
he might need other people
now check this out
i'm a golden state hater and i said this
last week golden state hater
not in the golden state because i'm a
clippers fan and they always ruined us
they ruined our chances i hate them but
they deserve more credit
golden state deserves more credit for
those two championships
clay steph draymond green steve kerr
deserve way more credit than we gave
them for those two championships
and they're proving it this year
golden st if golden state wins the
championship this year that's a real
huge indictment on
it's gonna hit it's gonna hit kevin
durant
just as hard as this
uh sweep
because it's gonna show that
they actually
knew how to use his talent so he was a
great talent and in it and it showcased
his talent and his talent shined in that
system
and it made him look
so good but they got a g-league player
looking real good right now they got a
g-league player looking like a all-star
like a first-team nba type well maybe
not that but they got him looking real
good what's his name um
what's homeboy from uh the golden state
war you know how i always never know
anybody's name
[Laughter]
what's the dude uh pool jordan poole
they got jordan pool looking like
man this dude's great he could start
someplace else he might not be able to
it it could just be that golden state
does that to players
players who you have to have talent you
have to have skill and if you have a
whole lot of skill you really gonna
shine i just feel like golden state
needs more credit for those
championships
um
and they gonna prove it this year
because
if you're looking in the west
i don't see anybody beating golden state
in the west and so if they get to the
championship like i say man they get to
the championship and win
that's going to be like yeah we did this
we didn't need anybody
and this would be the one the most the
most solid one so
like i've been saying about kevin durant
and kyrie irving i just think kyrie
irving
he's a great talent too but like
he wasn't playing
and then
not getting vaccinated whatever
do you
so then he was coming back and to me
rest is a performance enhancing drug
he was resting so he was getting 60
points and then not playing for six days
oh 50 points don't play for six days so
then it looked like oh man this dude is
good if he was here as soon as he
started coming every day and having to
play all the time it did it didn't work
out like that
so
that really affected the team and the
chemistry and they're just
you know
they're phenomenal talents but they're
not great teammates it seems neither one
of these guys
so then
this is the real indictment too
they on podcast talking about well we
don't really need a coach
hey bro
if michael jordan couldn't win without a
great coach who the [ __ ] do you think
you are
huh
for real
neither one of y'all are as good as
michael jordan
yeah neither one of y'all is good as
kobe bryant and he needed a coach
man when the lakers first got kobe in
shaq and they were doing good and they
had dale harris as their coach which
team would you want guys which starting
five would you want
nick van exel
eddie jones
rick fox eldon campbell young shaquille
o'neal with kobe bryant coming off the
bench ballin
so do you have those six guys that team
or the team that won the championship
what's his name um
uh ac green
ace
old ass ac green shaquille o'neal kobe
uh what what was the the point guard the
the the back up point guard for nick van
nexell uh and um and then and and glenn
rice old ass glenn rice like which team
on paper do you think is better
i tell you the one the one with the
better coach
like
duh
like everybody needs to be coached
steve nash made no adjustments he made
no
no effort to make to like let's let's
let's move kevin durant around let's use
screens let's pass more they got he got
outcoached and they got outplayed by a
better team
who also get paid to play basketball the
arrogance of kyrie irving and kevin
durant to think they don't need a coach
and so they they push that energy on the
team kevin durant like
when the bulls were at their height
at the third quarter no matter what phil
jackson would take michael jordan now
you got to come out because he needed to
rest him you need two or three minutes
let's get some rest so you can get back
in here and finish it out strong kevin
durant was freaking tired man you've
played so many minutes he's still coming
off injury it was that whole situation
is terrible that whole situation is
terrible and it's probably gonna blow up
again
he already ran from golden state from
okc i didn't like dealing with uh this
so let me go to this other team let me
get my championships ooh i don't like
dealing with them so now let me go to
the nets
guess what not gonna be surprised if
kevin durant is with another team next
year
not gonna be surprised
and kyrie irving who's only got one left
year left on his contract
does he even really want to play
basketball it's always something with
him you look at how many times he hasn't
even played a full season in like eight
years but this goes back to when he was
at duke he got hurt he's either hurt or
he's not playing for whatever reason so
i don't know all you fans out there for
all you kd fans and you're like oh he's
good man i'm sorry you don't get swept
like that you don't get swept sorry and
especially when you are the reason too
your lack of production is the reason
why your team gets swept and i wasn't
surprised in a game that doesn't matter
he had 39 points
not surprised because it didn't matter
even last year in the playoffs when he
had that phenomenal 45 points 17
rebounds whatever game
it wasn't an elimination game so it
didn't matter
when it matters
this dude sometimes shows up small
and i hope that he could turn that
around with either on this team next
year or wherever he ends up
but
from the looks of this from the looks of
this right now
that was a complete and utter
failure
okay the nets experiment their big three
and don't even get me started on ben
simmons
like whatever is going on with this guy
i don't care look you got mental health
issues
you still have to be held accountable
for your profession
okay
like if i have mental health issues and
it affects my stand-up comedy or it
affects like if i'm on a set then i
gotta go i can't be on that set i can't
be on set messing up the environment and
i can't say well guys i have mental
health issues so that's on them to be
like okay we're really sensitive to this
but then we're going to get someone else
maybe this isn't for you that's fair i
think that's fair so the guy with this
you know we had to we had to like deal
with that and so then he still hasn't
played you know now he's got back issues
and he's dressed up on the sideline like
i i just i don't know about that dude
man but from the scouting report from
from my own from my research i've done
in terms of like you know
googling this and and hearing like other
people other sports programs i listen to
a lot of sports programs talk about it
apparently on his scouting report
this was a part of his thing that they
questioned his work ethic they
questioned his desire to play and i
think that's proven itself right now
i don't know who won that trade but as
of right now the sixer the sixers have
won that trade but we'll see how far
they go but
yeah this is just
some bizarre nba season and you know
what shout out to lebron james because i
missed lebron
this the playoffs not the same without
someone like that and there's no one
like that left steph curry he's he's a
you know that kind of like
so hopefully he makes it in hopefully
joel embiid stays in long enough giannis
it's hard to like he's so
he don't got that thing you know you
don't got that thing where you're like
oh i love that guy you know you respect
his game and how he works hard but it's
not like that like shaquille o'neal in
the press i love this guy and guys thank
you for all the super chats man i
appreciate you guys dude
appreciate you coffee and
jag deep appreciate the super chats and
all the other folks that are putting in
the super chats i don't know why it's
not showing up it's not showing up on my
thing but i appreciate that
um
so we'll see man we will see what
happens with the rest of the way but so
far it's still so far it's pretty
exciting
uh so we'll see um but i'm predicting my
prediction right now is i i i think it's
gonna be
man i don't even know in the east the
east is so tough like i think boston is
great boston have proven himself to be a
great team but because of all the
nonsense going on with the nets we need
to see what they do in the next round
but if boston can get by milwaukee
they're going to win the championship i
think if boston gets by milwaukee they
go into the finals and they're going to
win it because that just they're they're
ready
um they've already been in the eastern
finals twice lost to lebron so you know
what i mean like they're ready
but if they if milwaukee should beat
them
man
that is between
sixers milwaukee or the heat and if i
had to pick between those three
if chris milton milton isn't coming back
from uh the milwaukee i would go with
the sixers i think joel embiid is having
that kind of year so hello m kelts read
this
idiot
but thanks for your dollar ninety nine
uh but if chris milton it doesn't come
back from the bucks i don't think the
bucks have enough to win a seven game
series
um so we'll see
so yeah guys that is the
nba talk
and be a talk
baby
nba talk
all right guys now i want to talk about
this show that a bunch of people have
told me to watch
and i finally watched it
it's
um
winning time
on
hbo max
winning time
um
it let's go to this here so you guys can
see what i'm looking at so when in time
it stars john c reilly
uh quincy what is this guy's name quincy
isaiah and jason clark and a bunch of
other people that like you know if you
see them you would know them you know
if you see them you'd know them right
um
yeah just just a bunch of people that
are like
whatever um but let let me
let's let me okay so winning time is
about like the rise of the lakers
dynasty
in the late 70s
i
i am not a huge fan of this show
you know i'm not i'm not a huge fan of
the show and
i'm gonna tell you why
oh by the way the poll ended for the
twitter poll and it says people you guys
think uh it wasn't it was a good choice
all right so that's great so
not a huge fan of winning time man and
from for a bunch of reasons
first thing is
i don't like just how it looks
so they got this sort of like 70s filter
on the show as if we filmed this in the
70s and i'm like that [ __ ] is just
distracting
it's distracting and it's like it's a
it's another character in the show and i
don't like the character there's always
some nonsense on the screen as if like
you know the technology's bad and we
couldn't get a good picture so they
always got these like little marks on
the screen and and weird effects
thumbs down don't like it
and it's just distract it's not
distracting it's just distracting
actually and it's distracting from some
mediocre performances if i'm being 100
or even
misguided performances i should say too
cause i think john c reilly is doing a
great job i just don't like the job that
he's doing you know i don't like that
character i don't like any of these
characters none of them
none of them not one of these characters
i like
because it doesn't feel real to me
when you do a documentary like a sort of
like fake umentary about
loosely based off but we have a general
idea of who the people are
from
seeing them for 20 years
it's hard to like
it's hard to to to accept it or wrap my
brain around it
um i just you know and you can just
agree i see somebody said i disagree the
show is dope so some people really like
the show now i like the first few
episodes and then it got really boring
like i find myself falling asleep uh
sometimes but anyways that's another
here to there if you like it great you
like the show i'm just giving you my
opinion and i'm telling you why
so for instance the guy that's playing
magic johnson
i really he looks like magic right it's
crazy how much he looks like young magic
johnson but i don't believe he's doing a
good magic johnson i just don't believe
like
we know enough about magic johnson's
mannerisms and and how he is
i don't this guy don't remind me of
magic johnson at all
and kareem abdul-jabbar who wrote a
great article about this
he says they've they've made magic into
a dumb a sex starved simpleton
and that is not what magic is man like
you know he probably listen magic
he obviously had a lot of sex okay
you know what i mean and we know why
the result but
he was still
seemed to be a very savvy person and
turned into a great businessman
you know and maybe he maybe he wasn't
like that in the beginning but the way
they're portraying him it doesn't come
across like a guy like this is going to
turn into this mogul that he became but
the season's still going on i'm all
caught up and we'll see what happens and
i'm going to tell you why i say that
because
so there's this big thing about the
jerry west character so the first two or
three episodes i'm like damn was jerry
west like this
they got him like the dude playing jerry
west got jerry looking like a a-hole
like he is just
and then it when you read when you read
about this it you know and i didn't know
this but jerry west
dealt with depression and he dealt with
mental health issues back in the day at
a time when no one even called it mental
health issues no one cared so they're
trying to portray that they're
dramatizing it i think they're going
they're going a little overboard in
terms of that kind of stuff but they're
you know so they have that part of it
they're portraying him as like a mean
spirited guy
and then they're trying to disguise that
as like well he does have issues and
he's dealing with those issues and
whatever and they're trying to play this
line and i just don't think they're
doing a very good job of that in the
early episodes
because
you know you want to see
uh this person who orchestrated this
lineup and who became this you know
savant when it came to drafting and and
and so i wanted i wanted to see more of
that so later episodes like 6 7 8
i'm starting to get a sense of that i'm
starting to get a sense that jerry west
became this guy who's behind the scenes
and and knows what it takes to make the
team great so they're starting to show
that i wish they would have showed that
earlier so i think that what they
established about the character it's not
very flattering to jerry west who is
actually out here
he wants to sue them he wants a
retraction he's like really upset about
his portrayal
now
i'm still waiting to see a bunch of
you know people who knew jerry who
played with him to come out and say oh
jerry wasn't an [ __ ]
i'm not seeing that you know but maybe
there is if you see that tweet at me or
put you know tweet at me with the
article tweet at me with the tweet so we
could see so i can come on here next
week and be like oh man 10 people who
knew jerry said this is all lies maybe
he was an [ __ ] but you know what i
don't care because that has nothing to
do with production
uh michael jordan greatest
arguably the greatest basketball player
ever he turns out probably he wasn't a
very good husband
uh
and he actually wanted actually a nice
person when it comes to like when you
watch his own documentary you see how he
was getting he
he was an [ __ ] all right and that's
okay
you know so like if jerry west actually
was an [ __ ] it has i don't care you
know like
it don't change it don't change the
outcome
um
and we don't really care about it either
you know
only now in society we're starting to
like
question people's character because
people are putting tweets out people are
like screenshotting dms and people are
like clout chasing to ruin someone's
life
uh
to assassinate their character it's
becoming important now because of social
media but like overall though i don't
think we really care
we would like people to be nice but it
has nothing to do with results so anyway
that being said
you know so maybe the these last few
episodes
we're going to start to see this
character form into something that is
you know more of like what we kind of
have the perception of jerry west but i
just think it's corny i think that the
performances are all like one or two
notes and i don't like it uh i think
kareem was right like kareem's character
comes off as this sort of like [ __ ]
stoic
you know all he cares about is you know
all he cares about is um
uh
the stuff that's going on in the black
community and racism and stuff and i
don't know if that was necessarily true
i don't think i think he was more than
just that i remember seeing footage of
kareem on the court
you know being excited about
um
playing basketball and they're
portraying him as this kind of like i'm
just doing this for the money and i'm a
yoga guy and i don't care about nothing
but this and so i i don't i don't like
that character i don't like how it's
being portrayed i don't like jerry west
i don't even like the girl being genie
bus
i like actually she's one of my more of
my favorites and i don't like what
they're doing with uh you know john c
reilly as bus you know he's just coming
across as this sort of like
eagle maniacal narcissistic sort of like
sex freak guy that you know he just
i think i think
there could be more depth and more to
these characters and
and i think like i said the way they're
shooting it with that dumb 70s filter i
just think that it's coming across like
we're watching some we're watching some
1970s corny ass white shadow type show
that you're just kind of like
you know i don't know if i'm learning
anything from this i don't know if i'm
being moved moved i'm not being moved by
this series at all and then they got
larry bird the guy playing larry bird is
like damn he's he what a
mean [ __ ] he is
right like there's no depth to him
either
but who knows
maybe larry was like that you know i
just don't like it i don't find it i
don't find it at all
it's not super entertaining i'm still
watching it
um
and i'm still gonna watch it
you know
but overall
it only overall it's only going to get
one woo maybe two
so yeah
i don't know man so if you guys whatever
you um whatever you guys think about the
show i'd love to see in the comments
what you like about it if you like it
tell me what you like about it if you
don't like it what are your reasons that
you don't like it i'd love to hear that
uh but you know overall like i say i'm
still gonna watch it i'm not saying the
show is like just
like completely terrible but i i do i
have some issues with it and i i told
you them i have some strong issues with
it but you know it is what it is
um so
there we go guys that's another episode
of riffing with griffin live in full
effect
i got changes coming to the podcast in
terms of like little things you know i
want to have more transitions and i want
to you know do more fun stuff on screen
and i want to put out more like clips
and content and i need help with that so
that's why uh there's gonna be a solid
main
producer person that's going to help me
take the podcast to another level i
appreciate all you guys for being here
every week all your comments your super
chats
uh patreons youtube members
everybody that follows me on twitch
you guys are a loyal fan base and i
appreciate your subscriptions which is
just like being a youtube member so if
you want to subscribe over at twitch do
that too man i i i appreciate that too
and once again thank you for subscribing
thank you for being here every single
week
um
you know it is
[Music]
you know it's a pleasure
to do the podcast i really
i really do have a great time doing the
podcast you know and it is just
i want to keep doing it for as long as i
can so the only thing i do is just keep
it making it bigger and better and i
appreciate you
oh frank with 19.
thank you for the super chat
mr kells with
1.99
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for watching
thank you for watching
[Music]